communist China trying to crush
anti-lockdown protesters and getting a
little help from Apple the big Tech
Giant blocked China's users from
accessing its critical airdrop feature
earlier this month it would have made it
easier for protesters to share important
info and bypass beijing's online
censorship Chinese police have
reportedly been stopping people and
checking their phones for foreign apps
and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is
ripping Apple for colluding with China
you have people in China that are really
engaged in a noble effort to protest
which is basically leninous rule so what
is Apple doing with that they are
limiting the airdrop function of the
protesters so they are serving basically
as a vassal to the Chinese Communist
party but Apple sucking up to China is a
new CEO Tim Cook said this back in 2017.
China's done an unbelievable job of
lifting people out of poverty they've
done an incredible job and I mean far
beyond what any country has done we were
talking about 19 mid 90s to today the
biggest change is the number of people
that have been pulled out of poverty
by far and we should all applaud that
so Dana you know you listen to that and
you kind of understand what he's trying
to do he's trying he believes that if
you do business with a place like China
you'll be influencing them in shaping
their culture what does he have to show
for this how has Apple influenced China
or helped China become you know
westernized or just better at you know
with their people reported 11 when we'll
talk to the uyghurs and see how that's
gone like not very good about a fifth of
the iPhones purchase in the world are
purchased in China in addition to not
only being made there this is basically
China is waging digital Warfare
against its own citizens using
technology developed in America yeah and
that it will continue the other thing is
it's also happened on Twitter these
Chinese Bots were flooding all of these
um sites with porn basically yeah to try
to I didn't notice
I read about it yes
um in order to try to get people away
from it the other thing that the Chinese
are doing is let's just say you are
walking to work or you're walking to the
grocery store you can get stopped at any
time the government has full access to
your phone they said where were you last
night and you have to tell the truth
because they know because it's already
in there and also you you are controlled
by a yellow green or red signal on your
phone it comes up and the government
controls that green means that you're
not you don't have coveted you can go
anywhere you want yellow means well you
got to have some restrictions red means
you can't go anywhere and you could just
be walking down the street and all of a
sudden it turns red and you have no idea
why well why because you were at the
protest last night and that's it and
they know that wow that's pretty crazy
so Jessica you're a communist
um
do you think that Apple this is just a
coincidence that they that this they
turned this off that they claim that
they're going to do this worldwide
anyway or do you think this was like
it's an interesting starting point right
I guess if this is to become a an
international Trend no I I think it's
business and we should be objective
about how valuable China is as a trade
partner for us so they're the third
largest market for our exports we're the
largest market for their Imports unless
people are willing to actually you know
put over a shut up about it and switch
using Vietnam or Thailand and we get
Nike out of there and you get apple out
of there nothing is going to change from
this but what's interesting about what's
going on in China is it is now such a
departure from what's going on in the
region I had dinner on Monday night with
a couple who live in Singapore must be
nice
sure we have pizza
um uh did they like the pizza it was
delicious we went to Arturo's oh wow
delicious you get the margarita don't
distract me
um
and they had been in complete lockdown
right I mean Singapore is basically a
police state at this point right they
had when they had traveled they had 21
days of quarantine stuck in a hotel
where they had barricaded the doors and
I said well what's it like now and they
said it's just like being here
everyone who wants to wear a mask
because a lot of people in Asia just
like to wear a mask generally is doing
it but none of it is restricted it's not
because of covid you go in and out as
you please don't ask anything at the
airports Etc and if Singapore is at that
place and you look at the dystopia
that's going on in China you know that
this is bigger than just something that
can go away in a couple of days after
you know we have a more strongly worded
statement which was what Tom Cotton was
suggesting I don't think anything anyone
can say at this point will stop whatever
Xi Jinping has planned there speaking of
strongly worded statements judge uh
DeSantis provided quite a contrast to
the current White House don't you think
yeah and I thought it was it was really
spot on the truth is that this DeSantis
is is recognizing that what's going on
in the United States is that the White
House is promising to Monitor and
closely look at uh Twitter because of
something Elon Musk may do that they
don't have any idea of you know whether
or not there's a crime being committed
but they're on it and yet at the same
time we've got an Administration that
can't even in in anything other than a
very timid reaction uh support the
people who are in China who are
protesting this this lockdown and the
violation of human rights that Dana was
talking about they call you in and they
know that they're going to arrest you if
you lie about where you were because
they already know where you were and the
truth is that we've got an
Administration that loves China Joe
Biden said a rising China in 2011 was a
good idea 2013 Biden said China was a
great nation 2015 and he said it was a
significant asset and in 2019 you know
China the folks are not bad you know and
that's great okay because Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden did a lot of business or
Hunter Biden did anyway and so while
Elon Musk is being you know they're
going to terrorize him for the First
Amendment we can't even put out a
statement that even even Trudeau in
Canada came out and said we're going to
ensure the China knows full well we
stand for human rights and there is such
a dichotomy between how we're looking at
the first amendment and then how we're
supporting Tim Cook in basically taking
down the ability of the Chinese people
to be able to communicate and and
there's one more thing about uh Elon
Musk they're going after Elon Musk he
provided the what is it the starlink in
Ukraine I mean this is a guy who's done
a lot of good for humans and I'm not so
sure that the Chinese have all right you
know uh Jesse China is definitely not
worried about appearing evil right I
mean they're oh they remind me a lot of
you
it's armies in these hazmat suits and
they've got they're behind Plexiglas
Shields it's it's like it's there's
nothing on Netflix
that comes close to how creepy this
looks it's a true horror story yeah and
I can't imagine what it's like to be
Chinese and live under that type of
condition that was an excellent point
think about this
Twitter is bad
and Apple's good apple has slaves
building these phones Apple's colluding
with dictators but musk is the bad guy
come on
they're welding doors shut so people
burn alive and then Dana brought up the
other day they're blacking out the World
Cup because no one's wearing masks and
they don't want the country to see that
the world has moved on so my China hand
tells me something very interesting I
yes I have a China hand not like you
know what I mean and he says we're
seeing the end of China I don't know
what you mean it's a phrase in politics
you'll I'll teach you after class
and you can either have one or two
things China disintegrates as a country
right now because you're seeing protests
in almost every major city tens of
thousands of people or you see just a
vicious Crackdown one or the other is
going to happen and many companies have
pulled out a couple dead Enders like
apple are still there but they might
have to have an evacuation plan because
if you're not out now
it might be too late
think about this though there's no
natural immunity in China and their
vaccines don't work and their Health
Care system is terrible so this is a
super spreader event when you have
masses of people congregating to
protests it's only going to get worse
from here and it's moved Beyond
protesting over covid it's now about the
economy Freedom so she or however you
say is in big trouble he's lost face
right you just add something
um Elon Musk everyone's favorite
Crusader produces vehicles in China so
the Shanghai gigafactory has the
capacity to produce 1.1 million electric
vehicles per year because it was just
upgraded because Elon Musk gets that
it's valuable to to do these things in
China and it is now Tesla's most
productive manufacturing yeah
they're getting jobs from this do you
think that those people are earning 200k
a year and have great it's better than
being locked down
slaves slaves
well that was an interesting turn to
this segment next time Jessica says I
have one more thing I'm just going to
ignore her
I mean not every day
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else